mais je massacrer ta famille massacrer
ta famille tu sais pas à quel point tu
m'énerves ça très mal finir pour nous
tous nous tous pourquoi tu m'as raté
deux fois une fois il m'attendait
j'étais en retard et il a menacé mon ami
avec un couteau et du coup la deuxième
fois où il a voulu rentrer chez moi et
le gardien la surprise mais du coup la
troisième fois en fait
qu'est-ce qui va se passer vous avez
huit fois porter plainte contre lui et
aujourd'hui c'est vous la victime qui
est en insécurité on voit plus de
solution à part peut-être déménager dans
un autre pays ou alors ouais tu as pas
changé ta vie à cause d'un problème
c'est qu'en fait c'est moi qui me
retrouve en prison alors que c'est lui
qui est censé être et moi j'ai plus de
liberté je peux plus vivre normalement
je vous rappelle la phrase du procureur
du procès précédent Cyril très
inquiétante il va la poursuivre aussi
longtemps qu'il l'aura dans la peau